hello and welcome to show commentaries
put your phone away dan we're talking
about four tickets on our upcoming
screening I'm never surrender here is
almost sold out nice segue
we're talking about the honest trailer
for Hobbs and sha are behind the scenes
process our thoughts about the film
stick around for some deleted scenes
include the next week's on his trailer
I'm here with Dan lon Danielle and Wow
Hobbs and John Knight Hobbs and show
this film performed at a fourth-grade
reading level discuss I also enjoyed it
it's 45 minutes too long which we
discuss in the eye but it's stupid it's
alright it's so much fun but it doesn't
feel as much like a fast and furious
movie as I thought it feels like it's
trying to sort of do its own thing which
is fine but I was kind of hoping but
when they took out is the self
seriousness the certain mark Vincent
diesel mumbling his way through the
monologues he gives himself superior
still has that twinge of like they're
kind of they're not playing it funny it
just is funny this is going for buddy
comedy they're smirking their way
through every city yes exact that's why
I liked this movie and didn't like the
less few I mean if you're a seven had to
be serious and I get it but like
particularly the eighth Fast and Furious
movie is that I don't mind the action
and stuff being crazy it's just when in
the same movie you're asking me to take
it seriously that's what I have trouble
like this movie was just like whatever
this is we're gonna Starling city -
right it was exactly the length is the
only thing I can't defend yeah that it's
long but if they reaches a very natural
conclusion
and then just keeps get to a beat that's
like this is where the movie ended and
then the rock was like actually when
you're riding like on your bike or
whatnot they're down by kids bike but
you're leaving the bad guys headquarters
it's exploding it's Chernobyl you know
believe it's supposed to be Chernobyl
some kind of power plant
yeah hollowed out long abandoned like
return to nature power plant and they
were underneath it that's like jiffy
lubes in Russia like standing in front
telling me about negative void
coefficient gosh so yeah our thoughts
are small short and dumb on this one so
let's just get right into the trailer
for Hobbes Shah versus Shah oh god
that's the sequel and the obverse is
show yeah of course
ballistic comes vs. Ferrari franchise
this is as big as ever but when there's
tension in the family a spin-off will
race to hold it together but hey what's
a family without a little dysfunction
some passive aggression and a crazy
uncle who shouldn't be on Instagram
keeping fast and furious presents Hobbes
and Shaw so pause I mean the current
state of the fast family is quite
fractured what do you think Vin Diesel
thinks of this movie is he like this is
only big because of me does he hate it I
feel like a lot of them were being kind
of shady about it like not performing
like I'd be it still did fine but it was
like not I don't think it performed as
well as the last Fast and the Furious or
something and so a couple of them were
being a little shady hmm about it I
couldn't believe the what's his name was
like yeah that's what happens when you
break a family up or something like that
yeah lots of thoughts yeah
that he aired someone needs to take his
phone away he just has nothing to do in
between fast movies like Michelle
Rodriguez like a lot of them who are not
happy with the rock I think is because
this is their annual time when they're
the biggest stars for for those two
weekends like when they rule the box
office Transformers drying up right at
the same time the fast franchise got a
little rocky must have been really hard
on Tyrese like he had two huge
juggernaut franchises and now it's down
down to nine he'd just go do another
coke commercial or something I said
where he came from I believe so I
believe that he was the guy with like
the headphones going through the bus
singing always model first he was like a
model and then baby boy he did that
singleton movie and that's what kind of
was his breakthrough I'm learning so
much about Tyrese I don't think Vin
Diesel's even watched this thing's like
it's like Voldemort around him like you
capped it it's like that movie you can't
call it by its name it's probably their
PR people or whoever does their
instagrams like there's been some
thawing of relations they've
complemented each other on some things
online I think this is business PR I
don't think because they're they're
wrestling guys like they could be
working us yeah maybe but not VIN DS I
don't think Vin Diesel can do a work I
don't I think that he is himself he is
purely himself and yeah I think he might
have gotten a little money you really
love street sharks that much I mean it's
it's I think that I mean because it was
stately right it was Statham on the
rocket either the thing about how they
determine who could win the fights to be
perfectly balanced I promise you it's
that times ten with it I think he was
also mentioned in that article as any
other one of those guys
not gonna like what he plays D&D I'm
willing to bet one of like the cave
trolls is named like the Brock does this
movie movie but meet the blog and Jason
Statham they're the same in every
meaningful way but Shaw is a bit more
fancy so they hate each other's guts and
by hate I mean they've been in love
since they got locked up together come
on it's prison you know he took my dad
and are so scared of their feelings they
hide behind talking about each other's
packages somebody's overcompensating I
apologize in advance if it's a little
loose align the pose my top small you
see this girl watch these two buff
testicle cosplays work together to save
the world of mission no one in the film
takes seriously the planets population
is in their hands I think we should talk
briefly about the MacGuffin of this film
which is a glowing broad BIOS smart
virus that at T on developed that
scientists developed to basically and
the anti-vaxxers gonna love this deliver
vaccines to everybody in the world right
just like by setting it off like a like
a new positivity to is it's like you can
you could program it in advance so you
got to release something into the
atmosphere which is a zoomin showed us
were tiny robots and you could program
them like genetically to like only
affect people like of a certain
biological like you could you could
filter it surely that won't be misused
right
you could just detect like everybody who
needs a booster shot I do it all at once
and then there was a special machine
that you had to be hooked up to to get
it out of you an individual right sit
again with the big zoom in showed you
that it's just sucking up the robots in
your blood only the robots not your
blood cells right you know like that's
the idea yeah so you need that machine
that can only be prepared by a licensed
bio technical engineer only two kinds of
would have the know-how to will probably
get to that again soon here let's keep
going we extract the bug up in virus
from Vanessa Kirby who's caught in the
middle of being Shaw sister and Hobbes
beard it is really weird to watch Dwayne
the rock Johnson kiss feels wrong but it
seems so hard he's even like he works
out his lips for a guy who's been a
leading man in Hollywood for so long he
very rarely has a love interest in his
movies right something he's not like
it's something he's not that into doing
on-screen I think it's because he is you
know an eight-year-old boys fantasy of
what a man looks like if they don't you
know know that women are too young for
girls stuff yeah I think that's fair I
guess but even when you see it it's like
oh like no woman could withstand yeah
it's like watching my uncle make out
looks weird when we see it just innately
or because we haven't really seen it
ever despite knowing who the rock is for
20 years if you were a more sensual rock
from the beginning
see I just like dive into there you
gotta put toe in first he really wants
to make Vin Diesel jealous he's gonna
have to start hooking up in movies
otherwise how's he gonna Vin Diesel
gonna pine for what he's missing yeah I
thought that his sexual chemistry and
rampage was off the charts sometimes he
has families in movies but it's always
like they're trapped in a building and
he's got to go save them he's not with
them was that romancing Baywatch between
him and I don't remember I don't recall
and I don't know I think there was or he
had an ex he always has an X right
there's only some reason for him not
romance anybody during the movie yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was for thought yeah
let's keep going looks about sex like
he's the 40 year old virgin just so I
can do the horizontal of the core movies
that were already pretty ridiculous
put her now full-blown superhero flicks
yeah - the origin story that explains
her possible so there was a bit of a
controversy after the trailer came out
in the writers room when Danielle were
you googling I was googling how to
properly pronounce inter-cell book
because with apparently there's some
confusion and it might be pronounced
different ways and first I discovered
that his full name is adria which is
something we hadn't known but when you
google his Elva one of the suggested
questions is what races inter-cell but
it just feels pretty pretty positive
that we've already got all the science
now I'm not now I just heard the line on
a superb ended in case anybody was
wondering like I think we'd what
nationality I don't be great if the
whole movie got in Samoa and then he was
like a real Rachel Dolezal Superman Wow
alright well I guess we can settle that
or not actually things you Google okay
let's keep going
[Music]
the MCU application of the car movies
that were already pretty ridiculous
don't think don't intend to turn down
full-blown superhero flicks - the origin
story that explains how they're
indestructible because I guess if Marvel
is the blueprint for dominating the box
office just do a marble I know the game
that's not yours
boys no you're not are you making your
voice is my steel from the movies
everyone obscene Tarantino's to get help
what no down to the hammer
although the rug would know exactly what
to do with Thanos his gauntlet credit to
Joestar for working in his I saw that we
were taken to task for censorship on
that because we said some bench but then
we didn't play the quote out that was an
edit made for comedic impact we were not
doing the word ass yeah they said that
we centered the word ass because we cut
away before sandy s we say ass they said
that we censored ass because her being
overly sanitized which sometimes we do
have to but that was that was that edit
was made for comedic if we ever do that
that's YouTube that isn't like right no
that's we have to censor stuff because
of YouTube but that wasn't the case that
was it that was a community if we want
all these honest trailers to go on
Disney Plus they're gonna
sorry there's so many other places to
watch videos online as the boys take on
a shitty tech called
with the power to control the media and
shape public opinion that operates I was
talking about this earlier is there so
the this shadowy organization its young
yeah can you know hack into the entire
world's media to frame people and to
take over Piccadilly Circus to like put
their faces up on there what do the news
editors and journalists at those
publications think happened when their
shows have been hijacked to broadcast
this like bounty this could be on me I
thought they had like undercover
operatives you think they're like making
the new like we make the news yeah pose
do we take over the unclear you have the
auditorium full of I guess just people
with headphones on just coating all day
and I I assumed because it happens like
that that they were just they create a
video package one of them has after
affectional then they just hit hack and
then it shows up on everyone's TV they
fed it so we got this covered with news
all
Fairey you could give that yet to give
any information news
it is insider I mean I thought these
guys are heroes they saved us from a
nuclear sub last week but cosmic book
news some people that don't do the
research and it goes what they well you
know well they're I don't want to start
a Twitter wagging the finger from damn
wrong alright let's get going
I mean Eddie uh but instead of punching
Mark Zuckerberg they'll punch a much
stronger evil robot Idris Elba and his
best yeah I guess it's he dress or
interest or interest it's gnarly
definitely not I always thought it was a
Juris supposed to diversity no one's
ever corrected me but he's probably the
world is probably correct right well the
Internet has collectively corrected you
well there you go
sorry I'm just gonna say Luther from now
clean with ya well there you go
sorry you don't get it right every time
keep going he's the very rich
this is Jill's favorite yeah just read
motorcycle onto the soundtrack and force
us to that's like - sees yeah just a
little bit sorry Billy I didn't mean to
I apologize it's fine we don't know we
have to keep going
great job yeah nailed it note forward
[Laughter]
believe one one four yes again that's
variance eue so I start trek into
darkness
oh yeah it was he wasn't that guy anyway
okay or sister listen to him wrap over
the chasey I was listening to it in the
office and I was like is that interest
and I looked it up its interest
featuring Cypress Hill good name you
haven't heard in a minute I believe it's
tsipras's one of those guys were it's
like okay this acting things good for
now but what I really want to do is
music that's his passion yes CDJs he has
a DJ series there was a movie no it was
a show called turn up Charlie it's on
Netflix where he's a DJ and I think it's
like he's a DJ that he's got to take
care of some kids some when the
soundtrack was definitely in his
contract though right I say there's like
two mixes of it okay let's keep going
but this Dermody here has just one
weakness to guys at the same and they
finally figured out what if we fight him
at the same time I can't tell anymore
so gear up for the latest chapter in the
fast chart by the way that scene is
right before the one in the rain and
darkness
fast cars furious faces and flashy buds
to check all the right boxes because
when you get the rock Statham and one of
the John brick directors you're gonna
get a tight action-packed 90-minute
summer blockbuster with an extra 45
minutes at it on because the rock wanted
to take a trip to Samoa store that comes
from a whole other movie ass working on
Diesel's character 20 years I like I
assumed there must have been some kind
of like explanation for that that I had
missed out it's so ludicrous to say now
like brother and sister sure you see
them in flashbacks right the same age
it's together well it's the same as I'd
forgotten about this but it was on FX
and the background on yesterday's FX
always says while I'm working around the
house and transformers age of extinction
came on and I had forgotten in that
movie they made references the fact that
Mark Wahlberg and TJ Miller right went
to high school together yeah this thing
with like I guess it's the leading man
thing I'm just like I'm forever young
well I think we should how old is Helen
Mirren so can we look that up I'll see
how old Vanessa college everybody
quickly
Helen Mirren is 74 years old okay making
Vanessa Kirby Jason Statham is 52 years
oh but does 31 look at 31 year old so 20
there 20 years 21 years difference
between Jason stays but still children
Helen Mirren had her in her 40s or had
these children it's more to say that
they show them at similar ages when you
say them is literally 20 years older
though yeah yeah so that's just what 31
looks like now we've conquered age Jason
Statham does look it's it's which what
happens to all bald men who go bald
early is we look the same age 4 right 30
years right and then turn old over but
he does not look like he's the same age
as Vanessa commission and he go like
this they're like she looks really young
like she got plastic surgery I must have
missed it that's good point okay keep
going you're a Russian super criminal
Eliza Gonzalez puzzle I also got her
name wrong it's Alya
I think Elia Elia Gonzalez is nosy wait
I know I know I think autocorrected and
then I just never know
rushon thank you that common Russian
name Isaac Enzo the patriot yeah so you
could've expatriated that's a good point
sir I'm sure we'll find out in Hobbes
versus JA yeah alright give God a
stronger Bell this Roman reigns ever
best clothes at all his contracts that's
just for people who watch wrestling
measures for no one else I didn't even
know that was a risk I only know I heard
complain you have to correct me because
I don't I'm learning more wrestling
terminology I'm sorry I heard that
wrestling fans were upset because they
were trying too hard to put Roman reigns
over yes that is true you just said it
yes that is exactly right okay I'm
learning and that means like make him
about like he hadn't earned it and so
the strings were visible because they
were pushing him how do you earn
something when none of it's a person who
didn't know who he was I didn't think
like why are they trying to make this
random guy look so cool wrestling
wrestling
ww had put him over too much this movie
was like he's just one of the guys
notice him okay they're all throwing
spears at the same time parts only small
actors that basement spies use man
special agent Pikachu Rolo a car war
story I like that one that's great that
harkens back to I believe the two ago we
called the fast furious car wars episode
something something something so we were
trying to decide on names and we thought
like well let's keep the car worst thing
going over and then yes spin-off yeah
continuity Broll oh yeah oh oh it makes
sense yeah okay because he killed Han
and like dozens of other innocent people
next your voice Oh pause we didn't
relate well posits over we didn't really
touch on that is the absolute lack of
any explanation for why they hate each
other I mean because he's more stylish
than the Iraqi he's more like tailored
and drives a nicer car but you see even
in there like morning routines that are
side by side doing the exact same thing
yeah trying to with the lady this by the
way it's a problem with the whole movie
like that they want to have this
conflict because it's easier to write
and it's better for banter that's more
fun if they're constantly but they never
come up with any compelling reason for
these two guys not to get along and it's
like after a while just they would have
worked better if they kept the ROC's
character consistent from Fast Five and
he is the hard-ass heavy like gonna go
after you no holds barred and like would
have taken his sister to jail or killed
or whatever
I'm gonna do in my own way to make jokes
about the horizontal it's really because
it's like you could just they don't have
anywhere comically to go the conflict so
that's why they just didn't have like
you look stupid you got a dumb face it's
because they're not fighting about
anything there's nothing there writing
me a lot of grumpy old men which is the
point of Walter Matthau and Jack Lemmon
the movie is that it's rational they're
they have no reason to each other so all
their fights like this because yeah
field man where they say to each other
you know I've only seen grumpy you're
old keep up everything so grumpy it's
like there's a lot of that there's a lot
I say let's see some deleted teams if we
have any story Jack Ryan
Captain America force is actual cheap
meal that's mo what I am his Instagram
muscles glasses transporter feelings
have now betrayed her to Kirby's
Adventure the magnificent marvelous mad
madam m4 in the sky reference in
Terminator
bake for 10 the opposite of canceling
the apocalypse nitrous caliber robot
little rock beating a dipper wars and
two guys a girl and a single race hey
Ryan it's your friends and honest
trailers
listen it's not the case of aviation
jin-gi bro - for the money the even more
Expendables Hobbes's and Shaw come on
you put some stank on that line
now that's how you talk about choppers
so there's a character named Hobbs and
one named LOC who's probably the big
villain who whales can't wait for a
sequel that's two hours of them debating
political philosophy namely the finer
points of social contract theory kiss me
one day I just hope that I walk through
that door and I see the two of you
sitting there Wow
sucks to be Owen you had another son yes
yeah she still does he's in the hospital
right he's pretty good too ya know mom
doesn't care and that other one we
didn't use that's Ryan Reynolds voice
okay the villain with the distorted
voice like after about 30 seconds I
remember in the theater I turned
tomorrow and I was like oh it's Ryan
it's like Ryan take the distortion off a
little bit cause it kind of the
distortion of
so he occasionally draws the distortion
obviously Ryan row so you can hear that
it's Ryan Reynolds doesn't he do this if
it's not gonna be he's gonna be a big
deal in the next movie I mean I know
that he likes doing fun things but but
then he was on the Korean version of the
masked singer but they leave it a big
mystery who the villainous for the next
time and then there's I'm not
exaggerating I think seven after credit
scenes and it's like okay five seven and
one of these they're gonna make the
biggest he's in one of you they're gonna
make the big of no move and I don't
maybe we're wrong maybe this is a mr. X
but watching the movie the voice and
quite obviously right I think it was
great in IMDB credits as that boy is I
don't think the studio listed him like
that but it would be a great misdirect
if it's Rob Delaney that's why it's such
a great twist mention a rock I mean I
love Ryan Reynolds but come on those two
you have to give them a super suit let's
get into your questions and comments a
lot of people
fukiko you lose Khan and kkn all rights
he killed Han commentaries questions do
you guys ever care that he killed Han
yeah you care he talks about how he's
misunderstood and like there's like I
understand that but also like yeah they
really kind of sweep that under the yeah
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter he's
on the right side yeah care did the rest
of them seem to have already gotten over
it
maybe hice but like yeah the last movie
where like you're all working yeah
say it's a lot weirder for like dumb and
that side of the crew to still be okay
with them because they were very close
to hama even see Hobbs didn't really
know her on that way so I could see like
okay it's like people get hurt sometimes
all those people to break his brother
out of the hospital I mean a lot of them
could have just been very badly wounded
it doesn't matter because they think
that Han is going to show up alive in
the next fast movie oh do that twice yes
you can kill somebody off twice but give
somebody like a mind swap he doesn't die
at the very end of Tokyo that's great on
the sidelines for they just yet Tiana's
gonna rebuild him cuz he's like they
realize the missing piece was family and
they're gonna use him to infiltrate the
group honestly this is good maybe he'll
be part of the car Lucas black drives
the car talks
[Laughter]
right finally now Spencer can do is
jason statham voice the commentary I
haven't done that enough you're right
the next one we're gonna don't [ __ ]
we're gonna submission from gaming until
you get the franchise you know any of
the old characters in this if Jason
Statham played a muppet alone I'm gonna
say one more thing about more Jason
Statham impression you're gonna get it
keep writing into the job stupid face
rot here is where my boot is gonna go
mm-hm and then you're gonna hit the
floor not feel so much like a fan like
yeah there's no the extended world of
faster Furious doesn't ever never get
training you thought that was coming
when it's like okay I know a mechanic
alright partners right yeah she she like
jumped off the file with Letty and she
died and I was that was the diesel it's
Vin Diesel's Brazilian she first showed
up at 2 fast 2 furious and then we see
just one quick scene with her at the end
where I think she like tells the rock
about Jessica Szohr something I thought
she's the one that dropped off letting
my rights like guess what
yeah Letty's resurface yeah so yeah
perfect opportunity to bring like a
character like her in or it's somebody
who's been in the venture towards it out
now they don't go figure
alright slurpy 88 writes your Fast &
Furious franchise movie rankings well I
don't know mall in front of me but it's
really like Fast Five
and then the rest of the new ones five
six seven now I like five one mm-hmm
five one then like six seven eight and
then two for Tokyo Drift five probably
seven and this movie about together then
six and then you can really shuffle the
rest of them I'm not the biggest merge
so you can really stuff for the rest I
think it's five six and seven is a
trilogy and like that's the peak like
that's that's high and then like seven I
would say is like the other best one and
then six is pretty good but those three
taken together is like that's what I
always want this trilogy the Star Trek
two three and four I totally agree
that's the perfect there's a really
great trilogy embedded in this pretty
good franchise
Tokyo Drift definitely at the bottom
yeah I think is worse
it's got foul with like a Motorola
sidekick yeah he does wink at the camera
and also because of the way the
chronology works he's like in the future
but also using game boys that was the
first one Justin Lin came on board it's
like the action scenes finally start
coming together and like I think they
sort of figure out the tone a little
better
she was pretty dreadful to think the
racing scenes just aren't there like the
action isn't as good as you want settles
car versus boat it's pretty cool yeah
well speaking of other shows we're gonna
do this one again next week where we'll
be discussing next week's honest trailer
which would be a tricky one to get out
of
yeah definitely so we'll see you then in
there thanks for watching y'all bye-bye
[Music]